president Trump has won the Iowa
caucuses and he didn't just win it by a
little he won it by a lot he won with
more than 50% of the vote in his victory
speech president Trump did not take pot
shots and attack people and insult
everyone he actually was pretty gracious
and congratulated his competitors I want
to
congratulate Ron and Nikki for having a
a good a good time together we're all
having a good time
together and uh
I think they both actually did very well
I also want to congratulate VI because
he did a hell of a job he came from uh
zero and he's got a big percent probably
8% almost 8% and that's a an amazing job
they all did they're all very smart some
consider this to be uncharacteristic for
Trump I don't think that's the case at
all we've seen this from Trump forever
he's brutal when you go head-to-head
with him and then he's generally pretty
gracious in Victory